ويا لها من رحلة مررت
بها والتقيت بها هنا في عام 2019 ،
أخذني في جولة في هذا الموقع الذي كان عبارة عن
موقع بناء ،
كيف
تشعر أنه لم يعد موقع بناء أه
بالتأكيد
مكان للحظات وللتجارب
و  من أجل الذكريات ،
أنا فخور جدًا
بمدى تقدم الفريق وأيضًا بمدى نجاح
الجميع في جميع أنحاء البلاد في العمل مع الوكالات المحلية والفيدرالية
معًا لتحقيق شيء كبير
مثل هذا ، كانت
هناك دعوات قبل هذا
الحدث للمقاطعة
جعل الناس يسحبون لا
لا ، أعني في الواقع أن لدينا المزيد من
التأكيدات
والمزيد من البرامج المتحمسة بالإضافة إلى
نتيجة لأن هذه منصة
لا نتحدث فيها فقط عن نوع من
الترفيه الرائع بل نحاول إيجاد
حلول  للتحديات العالمية التي
نواجهها جميعًا
وعلينا أن نلتقي معًا وبصفتي
وزيرًا للتعاون الدولي ،
فهذا دليل على ما
يعنيه التعاون الدولي في الواقع ،
لذا فأنا متحمس جدًا لذلك  شاهد الناس
يكادون يضاعفون من التزامهم بالتزام إكسبو تجاه
الإمارات العربية المتحدة والالتزام بفتح حوار
وتعاون في
حين أن هذه لحظة هائلة
لمنظمي الإمارات العربية المتحدة الذين يريدون أن يكون هذا
بداية لمحادثة عالمية حول
بناء نظافة أكثر أمانًا وصحة.
عوالم